[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I'm here to welcome Jeffrey
Kluger to the [INAUDIBLE]
TechTalks stream at Google.
Jeffrey Kluger is the
author of several books.
In addition to "Apollo 8,"
which he is here to talk about,
he also authored "Apollo 13."
This was awhile ago.
It was published as "Lost Moon."
And he's also published books
on a rather different subject
called the sibling effect.
He's a science writer and
a senior editor for Time.
He's been there for quite
a while, two decades.
And he's written more than 40
cover stories for that magazine
over that time.
He lives in New York City.
So therefore, please
welcome Jeffrey
to Google in Los Angeles.
JEFFREY KLUGER:
Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me here.
I was mentioning to Alex
that just before he came up
on stage, I took a
picture of this room
to send to my 14 and
16-year-old daughters,
because being at Google,
that will impress them.
Nothing else I do impresses
them, but that will.
So I want to talk a bit
about the history of Apollo 8
and the historical
significance of Apollo 8.
And I hope you'll forgive me
if I glance down quite a bit
and do as much
reading as speaking.
Extemporaneously, I am
a shameless wind bag,
so when I write
things down, they
tend to be unmemorizable,
because they're just
too damn long.
So I'll be a little less formal
in our Q&A that will follow.
And the point I like to start by
making when I talk about Apollo
8 is that if there was one thing
clear to the people of NASA
in the summer of 1968,
it was that America
had no business going anywhere
near the moon that year,
at least not for a long while.
Actually, it was clear to
anyone outside of NASA,
as well, or at least
anyone who had any sense.
Yes, the country
had been eyeballing
the moon for a long time now.
In 1961, President
Kennedy had promised
that a landing would
happen before 1970
and before the Soviets could
manage such a feat, as well.
The Congress and the public
and the new president
after Kennedy's murder
had believed him,
and so the space
race was joined.
Now there were just 16 months
to go before the 1960s expired,
and only a fool would
believe that America
could stick a lunar landing in
the time that was remaining.
Just the year before, astronauts
Gus Grissom, Ed White,
and Roger Chaffee had died
in a launch pad fire locked
inside the Apollo space
craft that they were supposed
to take for its first test
flight in low-Earth orbit
and that later crews
were supposed to entrust
to take them out to the moon.
Everyone had known that
the Apollo was a jalopy,
but the clock was ticking,
and the Russians were lurking,
and there was nothing NASA
could do but throw together
the best spacecraft they could
and hope it was flight worthy.
Instead, that great
moon ship ended up
with three deaths
on its rap sheet
before it ever got
off the ground.
So the order went
out that it was
to be stripped down
to its floor studs
and designed all over again,
a job that could easily
take well more than a year.
Meantime, the lunar module, the
buggy, four-legged contraption
that was designed to ferry two
of the three astronauts down
from lunar orbit onto
the surface of the moon,
had arrived at Cape
Canaveral entirely unsuited
for the job it was
supposed to do.
It was too heavy,
and frankly, too
flat out stupid to fly in
space with the software
in its computerized brain
forever getting overloaded
or breaking down entirely.
And as for the Saturn 5 moon
rocket, the massive 36 story
machine on which the entire
lunar enterprise depended,
it had just two
unmanned flights so far.
And the second time, just
four months earlier, in April,
1968, it had vibrated so
violently on the way up
to space that it nearly
shook itself apart.
And the astronauts
aboard the thing
would have gone
to pieces with it.
The miserable state of
the American space program
seemed perfectly in keeping
with the miserable state of 1968
itself, a blood soaked
year that included
the assassinations of Bobby
Kennedy and Martin Luther King,
the Tet Offensive in Vietnam,
and the Soviet invasion
of Czechoslovakia, as well as
riots in Paris, Mexico City,
the Democratic
Convention in Chicago,
and in dozens of
American cities.
The great transcendent
triumph of a moon landing,
if it occurred at
all, was destined
to happen until not
some time in the 1970s.
And then, in August
of 1968, George Lowe,
the director of the
Apollo program office,
had a wonderfully unhinged idea.
He asked Chris Craft
and Bob Gilreath,
NASA officials who
outranked him in seniority,
if not, in inspiration,
to come to his office.
When they arrived, he closed
the door, and he sat them down,
and he said, in effect,
you know our schedule?
Let's screw our schedule.
Let's go to the
moon in 16 weeks,
and let's give the
assignment to Apollo 8,
because Apollo 8
can do that job.
And with that,
everything changed.
If Apollo 8 could make it to
the moon by Christmas week 1968,
it was going to be
much more than just
a political or
technical achievement.
It would be a threshold moment
for the species as a whole.
Human beings had spent nearly
the entirety of our existence
as low terrestrial
creatures, ground dwellers
forever trapped at the bottom of
the planet's deep gravity well.
In the previous century, we had
managed to haul ourselves out
of the dirt a little bit,
inventing machines that
could carry us through
the atmosphere,
and later, even above it,
orbiting around and around
the planet in a near-earth
zone we dared to call space.
But that space was, on
average, no more than 150 miles
off the ground, a little
more than the distance
between Washington
and Philadelphia.
Apollo 8 would break that
gravitational strangle
hold at last.
The astronauts would tear
themselves away from the Earth,
sail into the deep
waters of deep space,
journey nearly a quarter
of a million miles,
and then enter the gravity field
of an entirely different body.
Apollo 8 would not
land on the moon.
That would be for
a later mission
when the lunar module
was at last ready,
but it hardly mattered.
When this mission
was done, homosapiens
would be transformed from
a species of one world
to a species of two worlds.
There were a couple of
ways to achieve that goal.
The Apollo 8 astronauts could
fly either a circumlunar
mission, whipping around
the back of the moon
and coming straight
home, or they
could fly a longer orbital
orbital mission, circling
the moon a full 10 times.
By any measure,
the orbital mission
would be more dangerous.
A circumlunar flight was
something of a freebie
when it came to the physics.
Get close enough to the moon
on your outward bound journey,
and the lunar gravity would
grab hold of your spacecraft,
send it on a low flying arc
over the moon's far side,
and then fling it home
like an around the horn
toss from shortstop to first.
The engineers called it
a free return trajectory,
and that nicely captured it.
A lunar orbital mission would
be a whole different beast.
It would require the astronauts
to fire the main engine
at the back of their
spacecraft at least
twice, once to slow them down
enough so that they would
be captured by lunar
gravity and enter orbit
and once more to
speed the ship up
again so that they could
break free of the orbit
and come home.
The Apollo spacecraft's
engine, which
is the red bell at the
bottom of the ship,
was a big, roaring
blunderbuss thing,
and it was built
for reliability.
But reliable isn't perfect,
and what if it failed?
That was the rub.
If it fired once and
got you into orbit,
and then failed a
second time, that
would mean something much
worse than the mere death
of three very good men.
In that case,
those very good men
would be trapped,
eternally circling the moon
as the moon circled the Earth.
Around and around,
forever and ever,
sealed inside a $100 million
sarcophagus that would never
come home, but never just
crash into the lunar surface
and have done with it either.
The moon, as one of the
astronauts' wives darkly noted,
would be ruined for everyone.
No one could ever look
at it again and not
think of the three dead men.
That ghoulish scenario
argued compellingly
for playing it safe and
flying circumlunar, especially
after the 1967 launch pad fire
that made the wages of hubris
so lethally clear.
But there were
other things arguing
for a more ambitious mission.
Future Apollo crews would
have to orbit the moon anyway
before landing.
And if you couldn't
trust your main engine
to do the job it
was supposed to do,
then you never should have
built it in the first place.
An orbital mission would
also allow the crew
to conduct the photographic
reconnaissance that
was necessary to look
for smooth, safe landing
sites for later crews.
So the decision was made that
Apollo 8 would go into orbit,
despite the fact that it was
the harder, scarier, riskier
thing to do.
Because in addition to
all of those things,
it was the right thing to do.
Atlas rockets had been the
scarier, riskier choice
for launching the first
Americans to earth orbit
too, because the things were
exceedingly temperamental
and had a troubling tendency
to explode on the way up.
But the light weight and
the high speed of the Atlas
also made it the right booster.
So the people of
NASA just made sure
that things worked the
way they were supposed to.
In the same way, an
Apollo 10 lunar orbit
was precisely the
right mission needed
at precisely the right moment
in exploratory history.
And so the decision was
made that it would be flown.
Only 16 weeks after George
Lowe had his wild idea,
at 5:11 AM on December
21, 1968, three days
before Christmas Eve, veteran
astronauts Frank Borman,
Jim Lovell, and Bill Landers
climbed into their Apollo
spacecraft at the top
of the 363 foot tower
that was the Saturn 5 and
prepared for a 7:51 AM
liftoff for the moon.
The redesigned
Apollo spacecraft had
been certified fit for flight,
as had the Saturn 5 rocket.
Werner Von Braun, the
German genius and ex-pat
who had designed the V2
missiles that reigned terror
on London during World War
II and was now involved
in the more peaceable business
of designing rockets for NASA,
assured his bosses
that vibration
dampers he had
added to the rocket
since its disastrous
April launch would
ensure a smooth ride to space.
Still, the astronauts who
were staking their lives
on Von Braun's word not
impervious to worry.
Jim Lovell was assigned to
the spacecraft's center seat,
because the hatch--
with a hatch directly
over his head.
That meant he would enter
the cockpit last with Borman
climbing in first to the left
hand seat and then Anders
into to the right hand seat.
And that, in turn,
gave Lovell a moment
alone on the
scaffold-like gantry
at the top of the rocket,
waiting for his crewmates
to settle into position.
He looked down at
the far below ground
and noticed for the first
time the hundreds of thousands
of people and the tens
of thousands of cars
gathered to watch the liftoff.
He also noticed that not a
single one of those spectators
was allowed within a mile and
a half radius of the rocket.
A circular no go
footprint had been
stamped around the massive
violent machine that
was the center of
so much attention,
and the crew of Apollo 8 was
perched directly on top of it.
Lovell thought, maybe they
know something we don't.
He was joking
mostly, and then he
made his way into the cockpit.
Such mordant thoughts
notwithstanding, The Saturn
did its job.
Its five first stage engines
lit precisely on time,
producing the loudest
sound generated
by any human contrivance
apart from a nuclear bomb
and radiating shock
waves that were detected
on seismographs as far north as
Columbia University in New York
City.
Less than 12 minutes later,
the crew is in Earth orbit.
And less than three
hours after that,
they had lit the upper
stage engine of the Saturn 5
once more and peeled
off for the moon.
Slowly then, over the
course of the next few days,
the world began to turn its
focus toward the mission.
It was a world bleeding
from 1,000 wounds, wounds
that in some ways
were shared by all
of the 3.5 billion
people living in the 163
sovereign states on the 4.5
billion year old planet.
The people spoke 6,500
different languages,
representing tens of thousands
of different cultures produced
by uncountable
different histories.
And yet, on that
day, they all began
to attend to the very same
unlikely thing, the three
American men with lunch bucket
names like Frank and Jim
and Bill sealed inside a pod
of the spacecraft speeding away
from the home planet
at an unheard of 25,000
miles per hour.
The day after the launch, when
the men were 120,000 miles away
from Earth--
still barely
halfway to the moon,
but already 120 times
farther away from home
than even the highest
flying other astronauts
had ever been--
they turned their
spacecraft back around
to face their receding world and
pointed their television camera
out the window.
They took a bead
and switched it on
and invited the
rest of the species
to see the home planet
as they were seeing it.
American astronauts
and Soviet cosmonauts
had seen earth from
space many times before.
But in those cases, they
had been dog paddling
in orbit with the horizon of the
planet a mere arc beneath them,
not entirely unlike the way
it appears from the window
of a passenger jet.
Now Borrman, Lovell,
and Anders were
seeing the planet hanging alone,
unsupported, naked in space.
The earth was no longer
the soil beneath their feet
or the horizon below
their space craft,
but a complete disk of light
suspended in front of them,
a delicate Christmas
tree ornament made
of swirls and swirls of
blue and white glass.
It looked impossibly
beautiful, impossibly fragile,
and impossibly breakable.
The image on the
TV screens at home
was nothing like
the brilliant vision
the astronauts were seeing.
It was grainy, black
and white, and filled
with flickering static.
But the people living on that
world tuned in all the same,
by the hundreds of
millions, in fact.
And what their TV screens
couldn't show them
their imaginations filled in.
They watched it in Britain.
They watched it in France.
They watched it in
Holland, where even
the radio stations that usually
broadcast only classical music
suspended or interrupted
their programming
to carry regular updates
from the mission.
Iran's state controlled
television network covered
the story steadily and live.
Tehran's radio station
covered nothing but the story.
It was watched, too, in Central
America and South America
and Japan and Taiwan
and South Korea
and throughout much of the war
zone that was Southeast Asia.
It was watched in Africa and
Australia and New Zealand
and India and Turkey
and the Philippines.
And all of that
was before Apollo 8
had even reached the moon.
As the next two days unfolded
and as Christmas Eve arrived,
the Apollo 8 crew
at last sailed into
the gravitational influence
of the unlikely place
their nation and their
species had sent them.
Having traveled more than
230,000 miles since they
left the coast of Florida
just three days earlier,
they would now skim over
the Western limb of the moon
at an altitude of just 60
miles or a margin of error
of just 0.0251%
compared to the distance
they'd traveled so far.
Only when they had whipped
around the far side
of the moon, with radio
communications completely cut
off by the intervening
lunar bulk,
would they fire their
engine to settle into orbit.
It would be one of the most
consequential maneuvers
in the history of
human aviation,
and the three men would
be completely alone
when they executed it.
The capsule
communicator in Houston
called up to the spacecraft.
Safe journey, guys, he said.
Borman answered,
thanks a lot, troops.
Houston answered, we'll
see you on the other side.
And at that moment, the precise
second NASA had calculated,
the communications line was cut.
Alone on the far
side of the moon,
the astronauts were
flying backwards
and with their
windows facing upward
so that while their radar
system told them that the lunar
surface was barely five
dozen miles beneath them,
they could not see
that for themselves.
Soon enough, however, the
ship had backed far enough
over the leading
edge of the moon
that a small bit of the
ancient gray surface
stretched in front of them just
visible through the backward
facing windows.
It was a huge, ruined, meteor
blasted beach stretching out
to the right and left in a
changeless, gray-white expanse
that didn't stop until it
spilled over the horizon.
Lovell saw it first and
cried out simply, hey,
I've got the moon.
The other two men
sprang to their windows,
peered through them,
and fell silent.
More than 4 billion years
earlier, a passing planetesimal
had collided with
the infant Earth,
knocking it to the
cockeyed 23 degree
angle that would one
day give us our seasons
and sending up a great debris
cloud that, for a short time,
formed a ring.
Eventually, the ring
coalesced into a moon.
That new satellite would soon
become gravitationally locked
to the Earth, meaning
that it would always
keep one side facing
its parent planet
and the other side
pointing out to space.
Less than a billion years later,
the first one-celled organisms
appeared on Earth.
It would be another 2
and 1/2 billion years
before multicelled organisms.
Some with rudimentary,
light-sensitive eyes
spots followed.
And on dark nights,
those spots possibly
registered the
photons pouring down
from the brightly lit moon.
Later, other organisms
with better eyes--
and in one case, with a big
brain and opposable thumbs
and a consuming curiosity
about the things
in the nighttime sky--
would come along, too.
And in all of that time,
not a single earthly eye
had ever seen what the
six human eyes belonging
to the three men in the
Apollo spacecraft were seeing.
It would become a matter
of historical record
that the Apollo 8 engine
burn would succeed,
that the crew would
settle safely into orbit
and remain there for their
10 planned revolutions or 20
hours.
It would become a
matter of history,
too, that on Christmas Eve at
about 9 PM East Coast time,
they would point their camera
back out the window and beam
images of the lunar
landscape crawling slowly
beneath their spacecraft
to a television audience
that this time measured an
estimated 1 billion people,
or nearly one out of every three
human beings on the planet.
And finally, it would
become a matter of history,
too, that on that extraordinary
night in that murderous year,
they would end their broadcast
with biblical versus,
the versus of Genesis
that spoke of birth.
Apollo 8 could
never fully balance
the mortal ledger of 1968.
The lives that were lost that
year were lost all the same.
The wars that were fought
were fought all the same.
But that didn't mean
Apollo 8 couldn't
redeem the year, and
in some small way,
redeem the civilization that
had sent the crew out on so
outrageous a mission.
There were political,
industrial,
and scientific reasons
to go to the moon.
But we went to
the moon in a year
we had no business going
there, because at some level,
we couldn't not go.
Because we get restless
standing on one peak
for too long without
yielding to the urge
to explore the other peak,
because to sit on a shore
and look that the ocean is
to be haunted by that expanse
until we at last get
up, sail out across it,
and then taunt it back
from the opposite shore.
Apollo 8 was just that kind
of act of defiance and joy
and courage, too.
In a very dark time, it
brought us all a tiny bit
further into the light.
Thank you.
Now I would love to take
questions about this mission.
As I hope I conveyed, it is a
mission that's moved me deeply
since the days it happened.
And I was old enough, still
very little, but old enough
now to have watched it happen.
Any thoughts or
questions at all?
AUDIENCE: I once heard someone
describe the Apollo missions
as the world's smallest
most expensive pyramid
to John F. Kennedy.
Would you agree with that
statement, or do you think--
JEFFREY KLUGER: You
mean that in terms
of sort of great
monuments to human vanity.
AUDIENCE: Great
monuments to your king.
JEFFREY KLUGER: To your king.
Oh, that's fascinating.
No, I don't think that at all.
Look, I think Kennedy
was a charismatic leader.
He quickly became
a martyred leader,
and that absolutely
helped fuel the program.
The US had committed before
Kennedy died-- and remember,
it was two years between the
time he made this commitment
and the time he died--
so the US had already
committed itself
to doing this
extraordinary thing.
I do believe that
Kennedy's death made
it now non-negotiable.
Had Kennedy lived
and had he suffered
the challenges and the
swings in popularity
that any president
faces, I suspect
that the space program
would have come under more
intense attack than it did.
And there were plenty of budget
conscious people in Congress
who were opposed to
it, or at least opposed
to moving so quickly.
So sure, Kennedy's
commitment to do it
made it a moral, emotional,
romantic imperative for the US.
I would say that--
in some ways, if I were going
to be more cynical about it,
I would say it was the least
expensive arms race in history,
because it was an arms
race, but with arms
that weren't going
to hurt anybody,
unless, of course, you
took the spacecraft off,
say, the Atlas boosters
or the R1 boosters
and put ICBMs on them, which
is what they were built for.
But we tried not to
think about that.
But no, I think
it was an exercise
in American projection of
power, but of moral power
and of courageous power.
And I do not--
I don't minimize the point
I was making earlier, which
is I really do think
that this was a paradigm
shift for the species.
It was a hinge point
for the species.
It was the point
at which we decided
that we had the wherewithal to
venture off the only world we
ever got, and by some
rights, the only world
we were ever supposed
to touch, and say,
we can do this crazy thing and
we're committed to doing it
and we're committing to doing
it on a deadline-- by 1970.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
if the Soviets actually
had a realistic chance of
beating this mission to a lunar
orbit?
Do you have any thoughts of how
that would have been received
either by the world
or by the country
had this mission
actually been Soviet?
JEFFREY KLUGER: That's
a very good question,
and the answer is yes.
And I write about this at
some length in the book.
One of the things that
energized NASA was
in that same summer, they
had gotten intelligence
reports that the Soviet Union
was planning a circumlunar
mission, and in fact, was about
to launch them, and in fact,
had launched them.
They were two flights,
Zond 5 and Zond 6.
They were circumlunar flights.
They took the
easier route that we
were considering around
the far side of the moon
and straight back home.
On both flights, they had
small animals, insects,
and I think mice.
And in one of the
launches, the mice,
the insects survived,
but the re-entry card
or the re-entry
angle was too steep
for it to have been considered
a safe mission for humans.
In the second one,
the animals did not
survive, partly because the--
entirely because
the parachute chose
to detach about 100 miles above
the ground, which is no way
to survive a re-entry.
So the Soviets knew that they
weren't ready to do this.
Had they succeeded,
I strongly believe
the US would have
continued pushing hard,
because there were
still other ways to win.
We could have done
the orbit first.
We could have stuck
the landing first.
And I think had the
Russians succeeded, they
would have gone that way, too.
They also had a heavy lift
rocket like the Saturn 5.
But in the same way that I
said the Saturn 5 created
the greatest sound apart
from a nuclear explosion,
their rocket--
the N1-- at one point did
explode on the ground,
and it was the largest
explosion in history
apart from a nuclear explosion.
So they had some wee
technological problems
to overcome, and they did not
have the financial wherewithal
we had.
Communism was a
well-intentioned system,
but it never balanced its books.
So they didn't have
the money that we had.
AUDIENCE: So I had another
technological question.
There was a great circa
1950 science fiction
movie called "Destination
Moon," which Robert Heinlein was
the advisor for.
And people used an atomic rocket
to get to the moon with water
as reaction mass.
I was saying, well, OK,
that was a good sci-fi idea,
but clearly we weren't
going to do it.
But I was at the atomic
testing museum with our company
trip in Las Vegas recently and
saw an atomic rocket engine
that had been tested
in the early 60s, which
used an atomic reactor and
hydrogen. It was considerably
more efficient than the
engines we ultimately
used on the Saturn 5.
And I just wondered
if you had any more
detail about the
atomic rocketry trials.
JEFFREY KLUGER: The problem with
atomic rocketry was two things.
It was infinitely more complex.
And what you're doing when
you're building rockets,
which try as hard as they
possibly can on any launch
to blow up and kill you--
what you're trying to do
is minimize moving parts
and minimize risk.
So that was-- that
mitigated against that.
Also, a chemical
explosion is very
different from a
nuclear explosion.
As recently as 1997, there
was all manner of outcry
when the Cassini spacecraft
was launched to Saturn,
simply because it has a
small radiothermal generator
as a power system,
and that was basically
a pellet of plutonium I think.
And there was global
outcry about what
would happen if it blew up.
So I think the risks
were too considerable.
Now, as magnificent
as the Saturn 5 was,
there are some very crude
things about liquid rocketry.
The first stage of the
Saturn 5 was fueled partly
by liquid oxygen, which sounds
nice and clean and modernistic.
It's very cold.
It's cryogenic, so that
sounds nice and modern.
But filling most of
the tanks was kerosene,
so we were back in the
old era of the hurricane
lamp and launching rockets
with that chemistry.
AUDIENCE: So the movie that
came out a few years ago,
"Gravity," I know
there were debates
about how
scientifically accurate
it was with regard to space.
But the thing that
struck me most
was the final scene where Sandra
Bullock ends up on the shore
and is just so
grateful to be back.
Of all of the
astronauts with whom
you've spoken, both from
Apollo 8 and Apollo 13--
and granted, 13
had its own story--
have you noticed more of a
trend among those astronauts
to longing for space
or being really
glad to be back on Earth?
Is there some type of pull
that they have in particular?
JEFFREY KLUGER: That's
a fantastic question.
Just two things I want to
say about "Gravity" first.
There were a few physics
issues with "Gravity,"
but the thing that
struck me most
was that when
Sandra Bullock gets
back inside that spacecraft
after her space walk
and sheds her suit and
she's in the little boy gym
shorts and the little tank
top and it looks like she's
ready to go to Equinox,
she would, in fact, have
been wearing a
complete union suit
with 100 feet of
[INAUDIBLE] cable
in it and an adult diaper.
Now, that's just not as sexy as
what Hollywood was going for.
The other great
detail about "Gravity"
is that it cost
India $75 million
to send their first
spacecraft to Mars,
and India has been the first
country and only country so far
to get Mars right
on its first try.
Every other country
fails all the time
when we first try
to get to Mars.
Their $75 million
was less than the
cost to make "Gravity,"
so props to the Indians.
Every astronaut has a
different take on that.
Jim Lovell-- as I
say in the book,
I think Jim was never quite so
happy as when he was in space
and never quite
so happy in space
as when he was incredibly
busy and doing some crazy ass
thing like navigating
his way to the moon.
And I just texted him recently,
and I wanted to warn him,
because Jim and I worked
together on "Apollo 13."
And obviously, that story
was very Lovell centric.
And Apollo 8, Frank
Borman was the commander,
so it's commander centric.
And I wrote him and said,
I hope you like the movie.
You may have to wade through
40 more pages of Frank Borman
back story than you might
like before you get there.
And he wrote back, and he
said, as long as you remember
to say that I navigated those
two characters to the moon,
I'll be fine.
He loved being in space.
Frank Borman was a
very different man.
Borman comes across in
my book-- and he readily
owns up to this-- he was a very
serious guy, very hardheaded,
very much a grind.
And I don't mean
that in a nasty way,
I mean that in get the job done.
Now he is much more frank and
quite funny actually at age 88.
I did not expect that when
I got to know Frank Borman.
And I asked him
the question he's
been asked a million times.
I said, when you're
outside at night--
and he lives in Billings-- and
the skies are just glass clear,
and I said you look up and it's
a full moon, do you ever think,
I can't believe I was there?
And he said, I've tried,
because people always tell me
I should feel like that.
It just never clicked for me.
And he said, look, the
moon did nothing for me.
It was Earth that did it for me.
And Bill Anders
said that, as well.
He said, we went to the
moon to discover that Earth.
I think some of these
guys, when they get home,
they're happy to be home.
We shouldn't lose
sight of the fact
that we have just the coolest
planet in the solar system
and possibly in the universe.
It's perfect in all
respects for life.
And it's gorgeous.
It hangs in space, this swirl
of color in a solar system--
Jupiter's got some color, but
those are all toxic clouds.
We got a terrarian here.
It's magnificent.
So when you-- especially when
you're flying over the moon,
and it's a wasteland--
there's a reason that when
we talk about something
that's terrible and bleak these
days, we call it a moonscape.
The moonscape is one
nasty, ugly place.
It's dead.
It's gray.
It's dry.
It's windless.
It's got an ugly beauty,
but you can't get away
from the ugly part.
The Earth is
magnificent, and I think
there are some astronauts
who really want to be back
when they're done and
other astronauts who
just love the heck out
of flying in space.
So it depends on the person.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about how the astronauts
broadcast images from space.
I'm wondering what the
reaction was in countries
like the Soviet Union when--
were those images also broadcast
live on TV in those countries?
I'm sure there was
some censorship.
And if you could
talk a little bit
about how the USSR and some
of the sort of adversaries
of the United States
reacted to this.
JEFFREY KLUGER: It's a
really good question, and one
of the research tools that I
found very helpful that Jim
Lovell recommended to me--
I wasn't aware of it--
was a book by a man named
Boris Chertoff or Chertok.
"Rockets and Men,"
it was called.
It's a four volume set from
inside the Soviet space
program.
Back then, he was a man in
the room where it happened,
and he was aware of
everything that was going on.
And he said that, yes, it was--
nothing was shown live.
In the Moscow central
research bureau, basically
their National Science
Foundation outside of Moscow,
they did screen the
launch on a big screen
for just the people
who were there,
and it was under tight security.
And he admitted
to a funny thing.
If you've ever seen the footage
of a Saturn 5 taking off,
when that big first
stage separates--
it's about 26 miles
up at that point--
there are explosive bolts
and small rocket jets
that separated.
So for an instant, it looks
like the rocket blew up.
And then those--
that burst subsides,
and you see the first
stage fall away safely,
and the second stage ignites.
And he confessed that
everybody in that room
had an immediate
sense of-- there
was this oppositional tension,
because on the one hand,
all of them thought, it blew
up, we're still in the game.
And on the other
hand, all of them
honored the missile
man's credo, which
is that you never root
for the other guy's rocket
to blow up, especially when
three people are on board.
But once it got to space,
and it left Earth orbit,
the maneuver called TLI,
trans lunar injection,
which was the pivotal moment--
we're heading out to the moon
now--
they shut down the
big viewing room.
And they did
continue to watch it,
but they watched it
with just a handful
of people in a conference
room with a feed
they were able to rig.
I think they rigged
it from Eurovision.
There was-- the thinking was
some spotty pirate signals
across Soviet Union and
presumably across China,
as well, Eastern
Europe, any place
under the Soviet lock down.
And back then, the
right aluminum foil
on the right rabbit ear antennas
with the right Radio Shack box,
you could pirate
a crackly signal.
But for the most part,
it wasn't reported.
To their credit,
when the spacecraft
did get into lunar orbit,
they did report that promptly
on TASS.
Promptly means a
couple hours later,
which by Russian news
standards at the time
was practically
live as it happens.
But yeah, they kept it
as quiet as they could,
because it was a big blow
to the Soviet space program.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
addition to your answer.
In Soviet Union up
until 80s, there
were no direct
broadcast of any launch.
It was one exception, which
was Apollo-Soyuz in 1975.
Everything else was tape delayed
for at least two, three hours.
JEFFREY KLUGER: Is that true?
AUDIENCE: Yes, and it
was complete blackout
of 1968 and '69 lunar missions.
Again, it was exception
of newspaper article
next day that--
JEFFREY KLUGER: Apollo-Soyuz
was, as most people probably
know, it was a result of
Nixon, Brezhnev, Detente.
And an Apollo spacecraft met
a Soyuz spacecraft in orbit,
and they docked.
Shortly before--
that was in 1975.
In 1971, the Soyuz 11
spacecraft returned to Earth.
It was one of their
great space tragedies
only a few years after
our Apollo 1 tragedy.
It re-entered.
The guys were perfectly
fine as they re-entered.
When they came out
of blackout, there
was absolute silence
from the spacecraft,
and the ship had catastrophic
depressurized on the way down.
And they died.
Flash forward a
couple of years, we're
preparing for a Apollo-Soyuz.
We knew there had
to be an adapter
module, airtight adapter module,
built between the two ships
so that they could
dock properly and there
would be a tunnel between them.
And the Soviet Union said,
we can take care of this
if you want.
And NASA said, we'll handle it.
That's OK.
We're on top of this.
And Russia agreed,
and I think they
understood it was because
that was sort of a trauma.
That one worked nicely.
AUDIENCE: So first
of all, thank you
very much for coming and telling
us those very amazing stories.
My question is,
as you mentioned,
Apollo 8 was the first
in very many aspects
of space exploration,
including relighting
of the engine like three days
after the launch and high speed
re-entry on the way back.
So very shortly after Apollo
7 disaster and tragedy,
why wasn't this mission
flown as unmanned mission?
It's one of the unique cases
where there was nothing
sent before and nothing
was tested before
without actual people on board.
JEFFREY KLUGER: Well,
that's a very good question.
Actually, there were Apollo--
2 unmanned Apollo
flights tested.
One, Apollo 4 in late 1967,
which was a terrific success.
One, Apollo 6,
which was in early
'68, which was a disaster when
the Saturn 5 almost tore itself
apart.
The idea of Apollo 8 was to
jumpstart what was going on.
The idea was to say, we are
capable of doing this thing,
and we are done
being overcautious.
The agency had
become risk averse
as they certainly had a
right to be after Apollo 1.
They knew that their budgets
were always on the line.
And they realized in order to
keep the momentum going here,
we have got to be willing
to make this happen
and to put people on
board this spacecraft
and move the ball forward
if we have any chance at all
of landing on the moon by 1968.
There's one great thing
that I've always thought,
and that is we do--
as human beings,
we anthropomorphize
our machines.
So we send the little Mars
Pathfinder Lander to Mars
in 1997.
And we-- it was like the size of
a toaster oven on a skateboard.
It was absolutely adorable.
And we use words like
plucky and tenacious,
and I just used adorable.
We anthropomorphize
our machines,
because we just adore
the fact that if we can't
get to these places,
at least by proxy,
we can build machines that are--
I saw the Cassini
orbiter, Saturn
orbiter on the
floor of its factory
at Jet Propulsion
Laboratory in 1997.
Big thing.
Weighs a ton and a half.
Just huge.
And I looked, and I thought
that every single component
in that spacecraft was created
and handcrafted here on Earth.
It is an agglomeration of
metal and silicone and rubber
and plastic and all manner
of other components.
And it was built by highly
evolved human hands.
And it is a thing of Earth.
And in a couple
of years time, its
going to be a thing of Saturn.
Its going to have moved
from Pasadena, California
to this Saturnian system
880 million miles away, just
because we said we're smart
and we're goofy and we're crazy
and we're idiosyncratic
and we can do this stuff.
So that's how we
react when robots go.
When human beings go, we are
exponentially more thrilled.
Jim Lovell, Frank
Borman, and Bill Anders
did not go as Americans.
I mean, yes, they did.
And frankly, the fact that their
spacecraft had an American flag
on it delighted me, and the
fact that the first flight
on the moon was an
American flag delighted me,
because America is
my favorite country.
But homosapiens is
my favorite species.
And these guys were us.
So I think once you
got people out there,
it deeply and and instantly
re-animated the space race,
and I think that was
the reason to do it.
AUDIENCE: I hate to
be the one asking
all the cynical questions.
JEFFREY KLUGER: Cynical is OK.
AUDIENCE: But we all
remember the Apollo missions,
and we all remember
going to the moon.
But most people have
kind of forgotten
that we haven't been
out of low-earth orbit
for as long as
some of the people
in this room have been alive.
There has been no
one passed that dog
paddling that you
were talking about.
Some people say,
when somebody says,
if we can put a man on the
moon, we can blah, blah, blah,
and their answer is,
no, we used to be
able to put a man on the moon.
When do you think we'll ever
go back out of the Earth orbit
again?
JEFFREY KLUGER: Well, I'll
tell you something funny.
Tom Hanks said back in 1995--
and we're already talking
about more than 20 years ago.
We were at a lunch
at the National Press
Club in New York--
I mean in Washington.
And he said, the
thing that strikes
me is here we are in 1995.
We are making a movie
that is essentially
a period piece with
all of the women
in the movie with
beehive hairdos
and all of the men in these
fabrics not found in nature--
banlon shirts.
And the kitchen appliances are
all harvest gold or avocado
green.
Why that was ever
fashionable, I don't know.
And all of the cars are big
1970s, 1960s gas guzzlers.
And yet, they were
capable of a technology
that we can't do anymore.
They were doing things
we're not capable of doing.
I've always said that of
all of the millions of words
John Kennedy spoke in his
long political career,
there was a single verb
in a single speech that
was the most empowering,
and that was choose.
When he said, we choose
to go to the moon,
not because it's easy, but
because it's hard-- which was
also a very nice point to make.
We didn't have to go.
We weren't requested to go.
We were not under
imminent threat
of military attack or national
starvation if we didn't go.
We chose to go, because that's
what human beings like to do,
because we prove
ourselves, because we
assert ourselves that way.
I always say that you get a NASA
administrator before Congress,
and they say, well, why
should we allocate $20 billion
this year to NASA?
And he'll talk about
military spin offs,
and he'll talk about
technological spin offs
and security spin offs.
What he's not
allowed to say is, we
go to the moon for the
same reason we write poetry
and we choreograph ballets
and we compose symphonies
and we gather in stadiums
by the tens of thousands
to watch a football game that
has absolutely no meaning.
Not a single one of those
things does anything at all
to keep us alive, but
they are all reasons
we choose and revel in being
alive in the first place.
And I think we will go back
to the moon and to Mars
the second we choose
to do it again.
We have chosen not to do it.
I think we are in a position
to be close to doing it again.
The private industry
is nudging NASA.
NASA is getting close
to having a new rocket
and a new spacecraft
that can do it.
China is a growing
global power, and there
is nothing that stimulates
American initiative like being
challenged by somebody.
So I think we haven't
gone, because we've
elected not to go.
And I think we may be at
the threshold of electing
to go again.
AUDIENCE: Actually the
follow up question.
Can you share your
opinion about the chance--
or do you believe that the
current ongoing mission--
plan to inhabit Mars by
Elon Musk and [INAUDIBLE]
will be successful in the
timeline they are suggesting?
JEFFREY KLUGER: No, I
don't think Elon Musk can
get to Mars by 2024.
Elon is a force of nature.
Elon is a brilliant man.
I mean, here's a
guy who just said,
I'm going to build
rockets and electric cars,
and he's done it.
I was in his office once
interviewing him, and he has--
it's a cubicle.
Biggest cubicle on the floor,
but it's still just a cubicle.
And he has about seven
books on his shelf.
And they told me everything.
Six of them are
technical books that
are variations on how to build
a rocket ship, and one of them
is Walter Isaacson's
bio of Albert Einstein.
I learned everything I needed
to know about Elon from that.
Elon has done amazing things.
He is the first person--
his being able to
orbit a spacecraft
and bring it back intact to
a safe landing in the ocean--
he is the only
organization, SpaceX,
to have done that
apart from a nation,
apart from another country.
He did this.
He set out to do it.
He's done extraordinary things.
I think he can get to Mars.
But boasting that he can
do it by 2024 I think
is not realistic.
Saying that he's going
to send a crew of two
paying astronauts on
a circumlunar flight--
I think he said 2018--
I don't think that's doable.
I do think that's doable in
the very short range, that
circumlunar mission.
But I think it won't
happen in 2018.
And he might beat
the US to Mars.
He might beat NASA to Mars.
But 2024 is seven
years from now.
That is not happening
in seven years.
I'd love to be proven wrong.
I would be the
first to say I can't
believe I misjudged the force
of nature that is Elon Musk.
But I don't think that will be.
AUDIENCE: In the
long run, you do
believe that inhabiting
Mars will happen eventually
in human history?
JEFFREY KLUGER: I think it will.
Again, it's a question
of choosing to do it.
It's a question of developing
the infrastructure on Mars
to do it and raising the money
and getting the commitment
to do it.
I think that the
International Space Station--
which like so much
else, everything else
we built for human
space travel has just
been round and round and around
the carousel around the Earth--
I think it provides a very,
very good template for how
to do these things, because
it's a magnificent engineering
achievement.
And it was built,
and it's maintained
by 18 different countries--
by 15 different countries
and 18 different
nationalities of astronauts
have flown aboard it.
And I think using that
template for Mars,
you gather innovation from
different parts of the world,
you share the expense,
you share the work.
I think that's a
great way to do it.
AUDIENCE: So in the missions
which effectively didn't
happen, because we did Apollo
8 the way we did Apollo 8,
they were there to make
sure that things worked.
And so they had the
opportunity of going wrong.
Was there any risk that
we actually seriously
expected those
missions would avoid
without necessarily taking
the risk upon themselves that
was a risk?
Therefore, we were eliminating
from the program completely as
opposed to just
deferring it when we
decided to accelerate Apollo 8.
Was it just we decided
to pile up all the risks
and say, we're
going to be taking
this risk over the
next two years anyway,
so we may as well do it now?
JEFFREY KLUGER: There was
a lot of truth in that.
Apollo's 8 and 9
were both supposed
to be Earth orbit missions in
which both the Apollo command
service module and the
lunar module were tested.
It was not ready in
time for Apollo 8,
and they didn't
just want to have
another mission
in low Earth orbit
with just the command
module, so they decided
to pile up a lot of
the risks and go off
to the moon with the
Apollo command module.
But yes, they had--
the mission that Frank Borman,
Jim Lovell, and Bill Anders
were going to fly would
have been a low Earth orbit
mission with a LEM.
And they would have
gone up to about 4,000,
5,000 miles, which would
have been an altitude
record at that time, and done
a high dive into the atmosphere
to test the deep space re-entry.
And that was a critical
thing, and that
had never been done by human
beings until Apollo 8 happened.
And you hear about
what a roller coaster
ride it can be to re-enter
from low-earth orbit.
It's comparatively easy,
because basically all you're
doing is tapping the
brakes to slow down
from 17,000 miles an hour
to ease into the atmosphere.
Now, that easing
into the atmosphere
still generates temperatures
of 3,000 degrees
outside your spacecraft and
subjects you to four to six Gs,
so none of us would
want to do that.
But re-entering
from deep space, you
slam into the atmosphere
at 25,000 miles an hour,
and you have to ride
sort of a roller coaster
to come back down to
sort of balance your Gs
and bleed off your forces.
And then you have
a higher G-Force,
and you've got 5,000
degree temperatures.
So it would have been
awfully nice to have tested
that a little bit more
before the Apollo 8 crew
said, yeah, we'll
take that ride.
We'll see what happens.
So there were risks,
and they undertook them.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFFREY KLUGER:
Thank you so much.